hey guys cam here now I love being
invisible in video games I mean whether
it's engaging the clock in crisis
donning the optical camo and Metal Gear
Solid or even drinking an invisibility
potion in Skyrim being see-through in
games is always fun that appeal of
blending in seamlessly into your
environment and sneaking past dumb non
invisible enemies just never gets old
what about in real life how close are we
to actual scientific invisibility
technology
if you google invisibility technology I
can guarantee you'll come across three
things within a matter of seconds one a
comparison to Harry Potter's
invisibility cloak to a company called
hyper stealth biotech Corp and three
these sweet-looking photos now all face
value these pics are pretty impressive
and if you move over to the website for
hyper stealth biotech Corp then you get
some equally impressive claims and
information quantum stealth is a
material that renders the target
completely invisible by bending light
waves around the target the material
removes not only your visual infrared
and thermal signatures but also the
targets shadow the website then goes on
to say that the pics are in fact
mock-ups although they apparently
demonstrate actually what the real tech
can do however they can't show us poor
general public the actual technology in
action for reasons of security what with
it being tech marketed to the military
now while I really wish this was all
true I've gotta say I'm more than a
little bit skeptical I'm not saying it's
impossible that hyper stealth biotech
Corp have created this cloak is demoed
in the mock-ups and I do think it's
highly improbable and I'll tell you why
let's start by taking a look at the
cutting edge of cloaking research in the
public domain when we see a thing an
object what we're actually experiencing
is light which is electromagnetic
radiation bouncing off the object and
then back into our eyes so in order to
make something invisible then in theory
all we need to do is to bend a light
from behind the object around it and
then channel it into the eyes of the
viewer essentially creating a blind spot
for a simple proof of principle check
out this video of John Howell from the
University of Rochester and his Huey
boys they produced this neat little
setup using mirrors which does exactly
that going to the light from the
background around the person and then
down the lens of the camera equal parts
impressive and adorable
however this simple mirror setup is
unidirectional meaning it really only
creates a convincing illusion if the
viewer is standing in a precise position
okay but what if we want a material that
can surround an object entirely and make
it invisible from multiple angles well
then we need to enter the world of
man-made meta materials these are novel
optical materials that can bend
radiation around an object hiding it
from view very similar in principle to
the mirror setup the key thing about
these materials however is that they
exhibit a property not found in nature a
negative refractive index so what do we
mean by this
well every material including air has an
index of refraction this is the amount
that the object changes the direction or
trajectory of the light when it passes
through it water is a great example
we've all seen this effect when you put
a straw in a glass and then view it from
sidon negative refraction bends light in
new directions allowing researchers to
successfully direct electromagnetic
waves around and cook objects to very
specific frequencies of light rendering
them invisible unfortunately though so
far this has only been achieved in
experimental conditions with microwave
frequencies of light not actually
visible light however researchers at
University of Texas in Austin could be
said to change all this by using
electrically active metamaterials as
opposed to the passive ones we've seen
before by powering these materials the
researchers are confident they can
successfully cloak objects to visible
light too as well as microwaves now it's
just at the early research stage for the
moment mind you but it does sound pretty
exciting and this is just one reason why
I'm so skeptical of the claims of hyper
stealth you see what they are claiming
with these photographs is just so many
stages beyond the cutting edge of the
whole rest of the scientific community
not only is there technology allegedly
thin lightweight and inexpensive it's
also passive tech not active and powered
also this picture of the grass here
makes no sense right if the material is
in fact bending light around from what
is behind it then we should be seeing
the person she's not wrapped in it she's
just lying underneath and even if it was
somehow projecting than ground
while the grass should be dark not
illuminated you see it all just sounds a
little bit too good to be true and when
it comes to cutting-edge scientific
technology potentially worth a butt ton
of money when things sound like that
that means they usually are so
personally I reckon we'll have to wait
for further advancements and active
man-made meta materials before we get
close to a true crisis start cooking or
Metal Gear Solid optical camel oh and
one final thing to bear in mind about
this technology if we ever do create a
light-bending cloak that can surround a
person while sure other people might not
be able to see you you also won't be
able to see them or anything at all for
that matter other than maybe your own
reflection so it's never gonna be quite
the same as the invisibility tech we're
used to games however don't let this get
you down because there are some other
really cool things going on in the
worlds of invisible tech landrover for
example are using cameras and projectors
to turn the bonnet of their cars
invisible for the driver cameras on the
base of the car film an area of ground
beneath and directly in front the images
are projected then onto a head-up
display on the inside of the windscreen
effectively allowing the driver to see
through the bonnet and negotiate the
terrain beneath similar tech has also
been used to shine background images
onto a subject wearing a special cloak
made of tiny glass beads 50 microns wide
these reflect the light directly back at
the source given the illusion of
invisibility now while this is obviously
something that would not help you in a
stealth situation it's still pretty cool
so what do you guys make of this
real-life invisibility technology let me
know in the comments down below
last week on reality check I interviewed
mark Coulson about whether or not
playing MMOs could in fact be bad for
you now I just want to highlight a
couple of comments which I really
enjoyed user Matt cake said let people
do what they want to do people with an
addictive personality will get stuck
onto something better Wow then drugs or
booze or crap mobile games to which user
pong Lee added get them addicted to
particle physics then I want my damn
spaceship as always thanks for those
comments everyone and if you fancy doing
the same then there's the
comment boxes I'm always Wittering on
about or you can find me on Twitter at
camphor as Rob why not send me a tweet
okay guys I'll see you back here next
week for more science meets video games